première question accepteriez-vous de
modifier notre constitution pour étendre
le principe du non renouvellement d'un
départ à la retraite sur deux aux
collectivités locales les collectivités
locales s'entend dans les mairies les
intercommunalités les départements et
les régions
deuxième question êtes vous favorable à
ce que les fonctionnaires soient
recrutés sur la base d'un contrat à côté
d'un statut remanié pour les emplois de
prérogatives de puissance publique ou
régaliens troisième question
jugez vous que la mise en place d'une
rémunération au mérite et à la
performance pour les fonctionnaires
améliorerait la qualité du service
public et ce à partir de 17h qu'il faut
voter
estimez-vous quatrième question qu'il
fallait permettre la renégociation par
les exécutifs locaux qu'il faudrait
pardon permettent la renégociation par
les exécutifs locaux des accords jospin
pour augmenter le temps de travail dans
les collectivités locales déjà de passer
de 32 à 35 heures souhaitez vous que le
temps de travail des fonctionnaires de
l'état soit augmenté à 37 heures à la
condition de les payer bien sûr pour les
deux heures supplémentaires sixième
question que pensez vous de la
proposition d'introduire deux jours de
carence en cas d'absence dans la
fonction publique au nom de l'équité
entre salariés du privé et les
fonctionnaires 7e question êtes vous
favorable à l'alignement des règles de
calcul de la retraite pour les salariés
du privé et du public
8e question êtes vous favorable à la
suppression des régimes spéciaux de
retraite des entreprises publiques
neuvième et dernière question de même
êtes vous favorable à l'alignement des
jours de congé entre les salariés du
secteur public et ceux du privé
au nom de l'équité